[Music]
straight ahead on lawn crime daily just
before kyle rain house opened fire
another man fired a shot into the air
what new charger defendant joshua
zaminski now faces plus laying to rest a
fallen nypd hero i called
and then called again
and then called one more time
and this time i felt something wasn't
right and a plea deal is reached for the
father and son convicted of ahmad
arbury's murder how aubrey's family is
fighting back but first the deadly
waffle house shooting travis reinking
fired
15 rounds
in 19 seconds you're going to hear that
mr ryan king believed he was commanded
by god
to go to the waffle house we head to
tennessee where opening statements are
presented vaughn fine daily covering
court cases from coast to coast
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin nearly four years after the
deadly waffle house shooting opening
statements are finally presented in the
case while prosecutors say it was an
intentional act the defense says accused
travis ranking suffered extensive
delusions that include a famous signer
that shocked us all
back in 2018 prosecutors say ranking
walked into a waffle house in nashville
tennessee he opened fire killing four
people and injuring others
after a long and grueling 34-hour
manhunt ranking was taken into custody
the trial was put on hold for months as
ranking was treated for schizophrenia a
judge later deemed him fit to stand
trial ahead of the trial the defense
attorneys have confirmed they will
address ranking's mental health concerns
but will not discuss the issue of
competency the judge also noted the jury
will be sequestered for the entirety of
the trial voidier is expected to raise
that very issue of the insanity defense
ranking has pled not guilty to 16
charges including four counts of murder
where he faces life in prison during
monday's opening statements prosecutors
described the massive manhunt for
ranking following the deadly and graphic
shootings
the enormous resources that were
employed in an attempt to locate travis
reinking who ran from this crime scene
he was not at his apartment
there's a 45 caliber handgun missing so
he was assumed to be armed and dangerous
and he will tell you about the resources
from the metro nashville police
department
but not just the metro nashville police
department that they had assistance
from pretty much every agency that
exists
from the tbi the fbi the dea the atf
there were secret service assisting
there were other local law enforcement
outside of the county that were
assisting that they
gave a media release to the public with
information of be on the lookout for
this person
there are hundreds and hundreds of law
enforcement officers looking for travis
reinking along with the public is
looking for him
they are having to
shut down schools and put them on
lockdown and they are searching
everywhere
there are wooded areas by that waffle
house and they are searching everywhere
and you will hear that travis reinking
was able to evade them for almost 34
hours
the defense followed kind of agreeing
with a lot of the things that the
prosecution said but countering that
ranking has a history with mental health
problems and detailed delusions they
told jurors he believed god told him to
enter the waffle house that day and that
everyone inside the restaurant was a
government agent
what the proof is going to show in this
case
is that travis reinking
is severely mentally
he schizophrenic
you're going to hear that mr reinking
was driven by delusions
paranoid thinking
auditory hallucinations
one of those delusions you're going to
hear about
began with a taylor swift concert
where he believed that taylor swift was
talking directly to him
and then he went on to believe he was in
a relationship with taylor swift
that he was her real boyfriend
that he was communicating with her
and she communicating with him
and over time you're going to hear about
how
that delusion grew
and grew
to where then it turns
almost violent in his mind that she's
after him
that she's breaking in his house that
she's sexually assaulting him
that others are involved that the
government is involved
you're going to hear that mr ryan king
was so convinced of this delusional
thinking over years of time that he
himself was reaching out to law
enforcement
joining us today is criminal defense
attorney bernardo vilona and terry
austin as opening statements start in
the ranking trial bernard the defense
opened with rankings mental health
issues we kind of heard it there that
taylor swift and the u.s government was
after him how was the opening
so in regards to the opening from the
defense attorney the representative
travis reinking you got to think the
defense attorney did what he needed to
do the defense is not contending that in
april 2018 mr rankin entered waffle
house and killed four four people as
well as injured others if it weren't for
the help of james shaw who stopped him
for chewing however what the defense has
to focus on and what they are focusing
on is the mental state of ranking pretty
much they're trying to say that look
because he was so sick and ahead he was
not able to determine between right and
wrong and just to be clear not saying
that he's not guilty that he did not do
this in the end if he's found not guilty
by reason of insanity what happens is
that he's put into a mental hospital
until he seemed to be fit to go back
into society yeah it's kind of
interesting to see how that plays out i
wonder if he's sitting there thinking
well she knew i was trouble we're never
getting back together and everything's
changed but we'll see how that plays out
terry what were some of the high points
in the prosecution's opening
well listen the entire opening i think
was a high point i understand why they
picked dan norman she was incredible
when she did this opening she knew it by
heart she did not look at her notes she
was able to recite names and backgrounds
and the injuries and remember there were
16 people involved here six four of them
who died so i really have to applaud
what she did yeah great road map we saw
where she was going i think everyone
whether it be the jurors or the people
watching a law on crime network know
exactly where this case is going to go
we'll see how it plays out make sure to
continue to watch on the lawn crime
network
heading to ohio as the murder trial for
audrey cole gets underway the mom of
three is accused of shooting and killing
her boyfriend at their carroll county
home after the couple got in a fight
last may cole says she shot him in
self-defense cole and matthew mott had a
daughter and lived together after they
both got out of the army the two had a
rocky relationship at times which
included previous 911 calls over a
domestic dispute prosecutors say on the
day of the shooting cole and mott got
into an argument that's when cole
grabbed an ar-15 from under the bed and
shot mott in the hallway they say he was
found dead in the front yard after cole
called 9-1-1 to report she had shot her
boyfriend on the next episode of law and
crime daily we'll hear opening
statements from the prosecution and why
the defense has cole shot mott in
self-defense
and in hollywood chris brown finds
himself in hot water yet again years
after pleading guilty to assault charges
for abusing singer rihanna this time a
woman is accusing the 32 year old of
drugging and raping her back in 2020.
brown has been repeatedly accused of
violence against women for more than a
decade new documents filed last week say
brown is accused of inviting a woman a
professional dancer identified as jane
doe onto a yacht which was docked
outside rapper shawn diddy combs miami
beach home the woman says she was under
the assumption they were going to
discuss her music career the filing says
brown makes jane doe a drink she
believed was drugged then threw out of
bed and raped her the woman is suing the
artist for 20 million dollars for
emotional distress and charges of sexual
assault battery and rape
still ahead on law and crime daily the
city of new york honors an officer
killed in the line of duty hear the
emotional speech presented by his widow
but first is a plea deal reached for the
men convicted of murdering ahmad arbury
what that deal could mean for the men
charged with federal hate crimes
[Music]
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live law
and crime network with youtube tv for
all of your daily live trial coverage
legal news expert analysis and original
true crime programs subscribe to youtube
tv today and then locate law and crime
in the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle watch lawn crime every day with
youtube tv we put you in the jury box
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily the
prosecutors arrest its case in the
federal trial of disgrace attorney
michael avenatti avenatti is accused of
stealing 300 000 from former client
stormy daniels the government says
avenatti stole from daniel's book
advance to make luxury car payments and
to pay employees at his law firm the
interesting part of this case avenatti
elected to represent himself and last
week things got heated as he
cross-examined daniels and focused on
her belief in the paranormal avenatti
says he plans to call several witnesses
as part of the defense's case he also
said he's strongly leaning to it but
it's unclear as to whether or not he'll
take the stand in his own defense
kicking off its second week in the
federal court trial of the hate crimes
trial for the former minneapolis police
officers involved in the death of george
floyd j alexander king thomas lane and
two tao
prosecutors say the three violated
floyd's rights when their fellow officer
derek chovin knelt on his neck for
nearly 10 minutes in may 2020 ultimately
murdering him king was on floyd's back
lane held his legs while tu tau stood
nearby to keep onlookers back on monday
testimony continued with
cross-examination of minneapolis police
department invest inspector katie
blackwell
evidence similar to what was shown in
chauvin's trial was shared with the jury
as she testified about the department's
training videos and photos some of which
showed officers using their knees on a
suspect's back
of the three defendants lane is expected
to testify in the case he is the only
one not charged with failure to
intervene we assume that's because he
asked chauvin multiple times to change
floyd's position
also in federal court a federal judge
denies the plea deals for the men
convicted of ahmad arbore's murder
saying she's not comfortable accepting
the terms
gregory mcmichael and his son travis
along with william roddy bryant were
convicted of ahmad arbury's murder in
november 2021. in february 2020 aubry
was jogging when the three white men
decided to pursue him they say they were
making a citizen's arrest after they and
others in the neighborhood believe aubry
was responsible for a string of thefts
in the neighborhood including in a
nearby construction site the mcmichaels
were sentenced to life in prison with no
possibility of parole plus 20 years
brian was given life in prison with the
possibility of parole meaning he could
get out after 30 years the three also
faced federal hate crime charges for
violating aubry's rights attempted
kidnapping and the use of dangerous
weapons because of his race the trial is
now set to begin february 7th on sunday
news broke out that the mig michaels had
reached a plea deal that was vitally
opposed by aubry's family that deal
would have allowed the pair to spend the
rest of their first 30 years of their
life sentence in the preferred federal
prison as to oppose to the state prison
which they were going to go to in the
state case right now it is unclear if
brian has also struck a deal
let's bring back criminal defense
attorney bernardo villalona and terry
austin to discuss the mick michaels
terry in the deal that mcmichaels wanted
to accept we found out travis referred
to black people as monkeys savages and
even used the n-word expressing a desire
to use force against those he perceived
committed a crime was that shocking to
you
oh it was not only shocking brian it was
offensive and if in fact those words
were said then i completely understand
why judge wood would want to reject that
plea deal i mean those words are hate
words they're motivated by hate and the
deal would have given them just 30 years
in prison and so i think that the judge
is trying to make sure that we have
justice here and that they are going to
serve where they need to serve and not
get off easy in a lighter sentence now
bernardo the judge ultimately rejected
the plea deal that both sides seem to
try to work towards uh but do you think
the words of wanda cooper jones had
anything to do with having his judge
reject the plea
so i think that was one of the reasons
that judge wood actually rejected the
plea i would say this that any plea is
up to the discretion of a judge whether
it's a federal or state court judge of
whether they will accept the plea
however in this case we know that ms
cooper did speak during this process and
in that process stated her objections
you know with the federal criminal
victims right act that she was entitled
to speak when there is a plea and when
there is sentencing so i definitely
think it had a part to play in terms of
the decision by judge wood the question
will be is that where do we go from here
i will say this that the plea if this
case was going to trial can't be used
against need of these defendants
absolutely now coming up on law and
crime daily the ringhouse case may be
over but a key player in the trial now
faces new charges plus honoring a life
loss hear the emotional eulogy presented
by the widow of a fallen nypd officer
[Music]
welcome back monday march the 40th
anniversary of kathy mccormick durst's
disappearance this as her family files a
wrongful death lawsuit against deborah
chariton the second wife of robert durst
though a body has never been found kathy
durst was illegally pronounced dead in
2017. her husband real estate heir
robert durst was long considered a
suspect in her murder last fall durst
was convicted of susan berman's murder
prosecutors say he killed berman because
she had information about kathy durst's
death earlier this month durst died of
cardiac arrest at the age of 78. on
monday the same day as the anniversary
of kathy durs's disappearance dursa's
second wife was named executor of his
estate the mccormick family then filed a
lawsuit against chariton in her capacity
as the executor of durs's will
also in new york thousands mourned as
they paid tribute to the fallen nypd
officer jason rivera the 22 year old
rookie detective was shot and killed on
january 21st while responding to a
routine call in harlem rivera and his
partner wilbert mora mora were shot and
killed by lashawn mcneal who ambushed
the pair when they were responding to a
domestic violence call at mcneil's
mother's apartment a third officer shot
and killed mcneal investigators
recovered an ar-15 under mcniel's
mattress while searching the home a
different gun was used in the murder
detective rivera died just 14 months
after he joined the police department
he's among the youngest nypd officers
killed in the line of duty on friday
rivera's widow delivered a heartfelt
eulogy during his funeral services at st
patrick's cathedral
the little bit of hope i had
that you would come back to life just to
say goodbye or say i love you one more
time had left
i was lost
i'm still lost
today i'm still in this nightmare that i
wish i never had
full of rage and anger hurt
and sad
torn
although i gained thousands of blue
brothers and sisters
i'm the loneliest without you
our healths go out to the rivera family
and those officers affected in this loss
defense attorney bernard vilona and
co-host terry ossin are back with us to
discuss this tragic loss terry in her
eulogy rivera's wife called out
manhattan d.a allen braggs saying he's
too soft on crime do you think
challenges will be made after this
tragic loss
i do i think alvin bragg is getting a
lot of pressure that he's not tough
enough on crime but he says that he's
very tough on crime his new policies
basically have nothing to do with
protecting the police they have to do
with not detaining people once they've
been arrested and letting them go before
they actually get to trial so he says it
has nothing to do with the police but
we'll see i think it's having some
effect on him
now bernardo how do you think the new
york or the city of new york sorry can
make sure first responders are safer in
the field and our bragg's policies to
blame
so alvin bragg's his policies are not to
blame let's just be clear alvin bragg
has only been the district attorney for
31 days and when these officers
responded to that location there's
nothing about bragg's policies that
affected the response or how the
officers would have taken mcneil out of
the home taking him into custody and
taking him to the precinct so alvin
bragg is not the one to blame for the
unfortunate slaying of these two
officers all right thank you both when
we come back we head to kenosha
wisconsin for the coming trial of joshua
zaminski what new charge of the
defendant now faces after an altercation
before monday's court proceeding that's
next on law on crime daily
welcome back to law and crime daily a
man facing charges relating to the riots
in kenosha wisconsin following the
police shooting of jacob blake now faces
another charge as jury selection was set
to begin in the trial of joshua zaminski
prosecutors say he tried to intimidate
one of the witnesses inside the
courthouse demanding to see his photos
nathan de bruyne is an amateur
photographer who took photos that night
in august 2020.
de bruyne also testified at kyle
rinhaus's trial zaminski is accused of
firing a shot in the air before rinhaus
shot and killed joseph rosenbaum he's
also charged with setting a trailer on
fire that night zaminski's trial has now
been delayed until the end of march
terry there were fireworks before the
courthouse even started bail seems to
have been adjusted it sounds like this
witness intimidation happened break this
down for us how does this affect the
trial
listen i think that the charges against
him are so much less than the charges
were against written house and i think
because of that this trial is going to
be a lot different it's going to be a
lot faster and he's out actually on bond
just of a thousand dollars so i think
the system is looking at him as though
it's nowhere near as serious as the
charges against written house were and
in fact the charges he faces are with
this disorderly conduct having to do
with setting this fire and you know the
fire itself wasn't that serious so i i
think he's basically going to have a
much easier time now interesting enough
judge schroeder is going to be the same
judge on this case as was in the kyle
reynolds case how do you think he will
treat this defendant and will that
create any kind of courtroom
controversies
well we know that the judge in the
rittenhouse case who like you said is
the same judge here we know that he
seemed to lean in favor of britain and i
would expect that he might do the same
thing here he looked at the whole
incident at least based on my view of
that proceeding as though this was
something rittenhouse had the right to
do that he was working in self-defense
so i think he's going to look at
zaminsky in a very similar fashion all
right we'll see how that plays out come
march thank you very much and thank you
for joining us here on law and crime
daily we'll see you next time as we
discuss justice in america
[Music]
you